we in the last video we took the
maclaurin series uh
estimate not estimation representation
of e to the x now let's do it with a
couple of other functions list and and
and
we'll see in a few videos it all fits
together like a giant puzzle
well let's do cosine of x so let's set f
of x
f of x
is equal to cosine of x
well what's f prime of x what's the
first derivative cosine of x
well that just equals minus sine of x
minus sine of x what's the second
derivative
well that's just minus times the
derivative of sine of x so the
derivative of sine of x is cosine of x
so it's minus cosine of x
and what's the third derivative
f
of x
well that's just the derivative cosine x
is minus sine of x but we already have a
minus here so it becomes positive sine
of x
and then what's f4 of x
the fourth derivative
of x
what equals cosine of x again
and as we keep taking derivatives we'll
we'll keep repeating and and the the
pattern will go on right the fifth
derivative
of x
the fifth derivative of this function
well
the fourth is the same as the function
so the fifth is going to be the same as
the first derivative the derivative
cosine of x is minus sine of x so
hopefully you see the pattern
we're going to do the maclaurin
representation which is a specific
example of the taylor series where we we
figure out the values of the derivatives
at x is equal to zero so let's do that
right now
so f of zero let me do another color to
fend off monotony
f of zero well what's cosine of zero
cosine of zero is one
f prime
of 0 is equal to sine of well not minus
sine of 0 but what's sine of 0. well
sine of 0 is 0. so minus 0 is still 0.
so this is 0.
f
prime prime
of zero
well cosine of zero we already know is
one but we have a negative sign here
this becomes minus one
the third derivative at x is equal to
zero
sine of zero is zero so this is zero i
think you might start to see a pattern
emerging
the fourth derivative
at zero cosine of zero is equal to one
and then the fifth derivative i know
this is hard to read but you get the
point
is just zero again so what's the pattern
as we take the derivatives zero one zero
minus one zero one zero so it alternates
between zero and one so one zero minus
one zero positive zero negative zero
positive so every other number is a 0
and then between them we alternate
between a positive 1 and a negative 1.
so now let's use that information to
figure out the maclaurin
series representation so we realize we
we proved or hopefully well we didn't
prove that it definitely converges over
the entire domain of the function but
you have to take my word for it and
we'll experiment a little bit with the
graphing calculator in a few videos
we said that this representation and it
should make intuitive sense because when
you take the infinite
maclaurin series when you take that
infinite sum you're essentially creating
a function who where that function is
equal to your original function at the
point you chose in the case of a
maclaurin we're picking x is equal to
zero and it equals every derivative of
this function so
uh
i mean just intuitively it seems like
well if a function equals something at a
point and every one of its derivatives
is also equal to the function of that
point well maybe those functions are
equal to each other but i haven't proven
that to you yet
so we know that the representation is
the sum from n is equal to
0 to infinity
of
the nth
derivative
evaluated at zero right maclaurin series
is just a specific case of a taylor
series we actually haven't done anything
with taylor series i was hoping to get
there later but the maclaurin series is
a really cool one because it's going to
show us all of these relationships
between e and cosine and sine and
eventually i and pi and
you you will find it exciting but anyway
the maclaurin series is that times x to
the n
over n factorial that's what we said it
was so if this is our f of x f of x is
cosine of x what does this turn into
well
f of x
is equal to
well what's it equals f
f of 0
times x to the 0 over 0 factorial that's
just 1 right
plus now we're at n equals 1.
it's the first derivative at 0
f prime of 0. well that's just equal to
zero and who cares what that but that
would be x to the first over one
right
now we're at the second derivative
the second derivative at zero is minus
one
minus one
times
x squared over two factorial
plus
the third derivative at zero well third
derivative at zero we figured out was
zero
plus zero who cares what that is but it
would have been x to the
third over three factorial
and then
what's the fourth derivative the fourth
derivative
at zero is just equal to one
so we have times one and then we're at x
to the fourth
over
4 factorial so let me see if i can write
this a little bit neater and then the
next one the fifth derivative that's 0
times x to the fifth
over 5 factorial and we'll keep going so
let me write this if i can clean this up
and hopefully the pattern emerges if it
doesn't if it hasn't emerged already f
of x which is equal to cosine of x
is equal to let me just go to the zeros
one
and then we have
minus
x squared
over two
factorial
this term so this goes away this is a
zero term and the next one is a positive
plus
x to the fourth
over 4 factorial
and the fifth term goes away but then
the cycle continues the next one is
going to be minus because we have minus
1 plus 1 it's going to be minus
x to the 6
over 6 factorial and you could take the
6 derivative you'll see that
the derivative of minus sine of x is
minus cosine of x and that's where we
get the minus 1 from
and then we're going to go plus so we're
just taking all the even terms x to the
8th
over 8 factorial
minus x to the tenth
over 10 factorial and we could just keep
going on and on and on and on
and so we have a situation where
we can rewrite cosine of x
is equal to the sum
if you believe that this maclaurin
series actually does converge to cosine
of x
over the entire domain of x that's kind
of an assumption we're making
hopefully one day we can
we'll have the tool set to actually
prove that as well
from n
is equal to zero
so what's happening we're taking all of
the even powers right so we could say
x
to the 2n
right that ensures that no matter what
value of n i put in here i get an even
number so i'll go to the zeroth power
then the second power then
over 2
n factorial so that takes care of going
from you know 1 to x squared over 2 to x
to the 4th over 4 factorial 6 over 6
factorial et cetera but now we have to
make it switch signs like that
we'll just multiply at negative one
let's see what we can do negative one
to the
so we want the first term to be positive
the second term to be negative
so we could say times
minus 1
to the n plus 1. let's see if that works
when n is
when n is 0
what's
negative 1 to the n plus 1.
zero would be minus one
and then when it's one
oh no no when it's zero
oh right right when it's zero it'll be
no no it's just be negative 1 to the n
right right because when 0 negative 1 to
the 0 is 1 when it's 1 it's negative 1
right so this is
right so this will work out
so it's negative 1 to the n is cosine
and you could try it out right this is
the n is equal to zero let me switch
colors
that's n is equal to zero and here we
get x to the zero over zero factorial
which is one and we have negative one to
the zeros one so that becomes one
then when
when n is equal to one
this becomes x squared over two
factorial and we have negative one to
the one power so that's where you get
the negative one
and then when x when n is equal to 2 the
negative 1 squared becomes positive
again so this the negative 1 is what
provides the alternating numbers
so pretty neat we just figured out
another way to represent cosine of x and
it might be looking
a little bit interesting to you that
that that this representation
it kind of resembles part of
of the representation of e to the x
what's the difference between this and
the e to the x well e to the x had the
odd exponent terms and it didn't switch
signs but other than that they're pretty
much the same
so in the next video we'll do sine of x
and then we'll try to put it all
together i'll see you soon